how could I overcome my fear of driving
on freeways well one of the things you
could do this is Ellis is do a fair bit
of imagining driving on freeways and try
to make the imagining as realistic as
possible but then the other thing you
can do is again it's graduated exposure
if you're afraid of driving go drive
with someone you trust in a parking lot
on Sunday morning when there's no one
there and then drive around the block
and a street that isn't busy and then go
to a slightly busier street and then go
to a slightly busier street and then
find a highway that's like I'm just a to
later so that you know you could
practice merging and that sort of thing
and you got to build a plan say with 20
degrees of difficulty with the highest
degree of difficulty maybe being merging
onto a busy four-lane highway and you
could go at night and practice merging
onto the busy highway because it won't
be busy at night so I would say what you
do is you break it down into small steps
and then practice each step until you're
bored with the step and when you're
bored with it that means you're no
longer anxious about it and don't quit
you know like stick at it because it's
really useful to overcome a fear and
once you've identified a fear then
you've identified something to overcome
that can definitely make you stronger so
like good luck with it and get
professional like take a driving course
if you need to as well find someone to
work with it isn't gonna make you
nervous and isn't gonna harass you but
don't quit it's really important to
overcome a fear like that